[Musique]
thomas de créer ton nom trois personnes
ont été massacrées à londres toutes
trois répondant au nom de ben lac tu
diriez quoi si votre homonyme sommes
réputés hautement yard a décidé de
rassembler tous les bennes light vivant
à londres dans le but d'assurer leur
protection
qu'est ce qui te fait croire que tu est
le prochain sur la liste le nom ma
chaîne youtube c'est je m'appelle ben
like tueur est ici pourquoi vous me
regarder comme ça parce que je suis bac
moi j'avais même pas dit tous blacks
[Musique]
mourier
je voulais vous suggérer de faire une
petite prière tout bon conte est leur
âge égal ou moins le côté dangereux
c'est ma ville
dans son cas
[Musique]
qu'est ce que t'as foutu c'était un
accident malgré tout pas exprès d'art de
mental
[Musique]
tu peux me le faire là non non attends
attends attends on peut peut-être ses
congénères mais je t'avais dit
d'attendre des sources
[Musique]
encore un jeune qui s'est apparemment
retrouvé au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment
hier soir il est devenu la cinquième
personne tuée par balle à londres cette
année world et qui est un dieu stade là
il ne fallait pas voter dont ils vous
demandent ils traquent wanted et
tombeaux unitaire est la venue des donc
toi nico doit s'appliquer
tu viens d'où je suis d'abord un mec du
ghetto j'ai posé la question à mon frère
pourquoi peckham déteste le ghetto si tu
fiches et ce alors tu étais l'un d'eux
je la connais beaucoup de chanteurs qui
viennent de paix quel beau nom mais rien
n'empêche peut-être la première un mec
des gangs
je veux paniqué je veux seulement être
avec elle seconde où je peux les sachets
bien les gros buts à 1 c'est le frangin
de switcher on serre les coudes protège
te protège et tu protèges si tu avais
planté moi je leur ai planté encore plus
vite et doumecq moyen de peckham qu'est
ce que ça peut te [ __ ] est malade ou
quoi
tu ne l'ès pas s'en tirer comme ça c'est
compris qu est ce qui t'es arrivé ton
pote a fait ça mon pote ce moment-ci
junior je te jure que je lui aurais été
son compte mais qu'est ce que tu veux
prouver
tu sais que je suis pas avec eux tous
ceux qui sont pas avec moi c'est qu'ils
sont contre moi oublie pas ça
super et maintenant tu es content marvin
gaye sandman archiware c'est mon fils
qu'il s'agit je suis sa mère et personne
ne dit rien
c'est pourquoi pour un club postale qui
m'aiment pas nous
on va pas rester là les attendre la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
depuis le début tu essaies de me choper
mais là c'est moi qui veut échapper
attendez coupé et ça va pas rien vous
deviez vous tenir là pour la lumière mon
dieu fait sortir cet idiot je ne veux
plus jamais vous voir ne vous avisez pas
de remettre un pied sur cette propriété
le prix si c'est quoi ton milieu et
bilan
demain c'est le dernier jour de tournage
ensuite on rentre à paris
berlin est en plein état d'urgence ils
ont fermé la frontière est ouest
je dois vraiment agir évident que les
n'approchez pas ou je tire
elle doit déjà être dans un avion elle
est partie
j'ai trouvé le moyen de rêver de revoir
mes loose santa veys tu veux faire un
film
ouais c'est vraiment la chose la plus
folle la plus idiote et la plus belle
que j'ai jamais vu et quel genre de film
ce serait un tout petit film ce sera
facile
[Musique]
un projet de prestige du socialisme je
ferais mieux d'aller écrire mon scénario
je crois tu veux tout mettre en jeu pour
revoir une fille alors que tu ne sais
même pas s'il veut te revoir
[Musique]
la dernière fois que je t'ai vu tu
n'étais qu'un petit figurants et
maintenant tu vois là réalisateur âge
ignorait qu entre vous deux
tu sais que tu risque d'aller en prison
si jamais quelqu'un découvre la
supercherie
tu n'as rien à lui offrir le vérifier
vous savez ce qui vous reste à faire
oui
[Musique]
ne retourne pas à paris je ne peux pas
rester ici mais ce sont des enfants et
vous vous n'êtes qu'un traducteur
[Musique]
mon écharpe
salut moment ça va manquer
et anniversaire mon chéri termine gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu veux avoir affaire à moi tu es castan
mauviette yoplait
[Applaudissements]
john woo cg64 allez me parler du gâteau
maritsa espèce de gros nuls où tu m'as
avoir à faire la loi
est-ce que j'ai vraiment entendu ça où
j'ai rêvé de la nourriture au partage
d'actifs toi je suis un guerrier je vais
mourir et ce à cause de toi va vouloir
me dû affronter problème c'est
impossible ce papa tu es t d si notre
terrain de jeu on la construit avec
odyssée je confierais pas ma maison j'ai
promis de t d et toi de faire de même en
retour
ce fut génial et ctvolympics ça
bouchonne
m
au chili peppers min est un monstre
il exploite des enfants pour fabriquer
ses joues et tu es qui toi d'abord je
suis ton nouveau meilleur ami
non mais
withings avril
[Musique]
elle y va
animer ce week-end
[Musique]
ben aknoun et sky
c
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
regarde c'est notre maison oui notre
mission
[Musique]
don de dieu alors ça j'y crois pas kate
personnes vous l'a dit les derniers
propriétaires ils ont été tués dans
cette maison
j'ai envie d'une bouteille je vais pas
vraiment godié bien sûr et comment c'est
arrivé ici
qu'est ce que tu désires le plus sombre
je veux un million de dollars pourquoi j
à
vous vous amusez dire
sur une réponse 7 conseils que vous avez
besoin de casser vous qu'il soit trop
tard
l'équipe de ron jans les connais des
créatures esclaves du désir pour vous
les plus toujours plus
et finalement vous crever
où je sais que tu voulais que ça se
passe en travaux
[Musique]
vous y jouez vous lui
calais
mais c'est comme ça
[Musique]
etiez-vous balsa
et
des trois journées
[Musique]
dora peut joindre of use
jackson sur thomas gilou
en valais c'est thierry monti
comment tu nous as trouvé
nous
tu m'as être un pas
la même chose à toi mais là c'est du
suicide
[Musique]
j'espère que tu vas t'en tirer
j'ai pas le choix je dois y aller
tout a un prix
[Musique]
on aurait pu te tuer vous auriez
peut-être dû
[Musique]
cette émission
aïe
cette étude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]